this sounds like a great time to talk
about what an observer is
so an observer in this sense
is basically an inference device
if we're talking so an observer we could
be thinking about there's many different
frameworks the way that i know how to
phrase this okay this is a digression um
or a diversion i'll i'll come back i'm
circling around um
so
when i
do
my own
personal philosophizing if that's the
world when i built when i
construct configure my own
internal
dwelling that's got to do with that i
call the philosophy house
so to speak
what what it really amounts to is the
following that there are different
i'm almost exclusively interested in
metaphysics i frankly couldn't care less
about philosophy of um art for example i
think it's an oxymoron
philosophy of morality i think
kharsany's got some interesting things
to say
rawls um less so singer i think has some
interesting things to say
but not all that much more than that um
but so mostly it's metaphysics in other
words what is reality and so on and so
forth
and basically as you strip and what
philosophy house
is built upon is the understanding that
you can do certain investigations where
you make certain assumptions
then when you weaken those assumptions a
lot of it falls apart and you get to a
deeper level of reality where there's
less structure
weaken assumptions and you keep going
down and down and down until the whole
thing actually eats itself
so
up at one level
i'm more than happy to be a steadfast
card-carrying member of the school of
people call themselves scientists
scientific realists whatever you might
want to call it
then at another level
you can start to say well what is
reality you can't even define it
and
you start to then start worrying about
things like inference devices
you can then say wait a second combine
what you just
said about no reality is more real than
any other that all of them are just
different these subsets
of possible universes that
you can have define these inference
devices structures that's all that any
reality is
that none is any
is a privilege over any other
doesn't that also can't you also then
apply that to your own reasoning your
own question answer process
and conclude that that itself is going
to be illegitimate in a sort of apost
demons kind of sense
so you've just concluded that no reality
is privileged above any other
but in doing so if you want to strip
down the very last remaining assumption
you are not allowed to assume that your
reasoning process itself is somehow
proof against
that kind of conclusion
and so as was put in i think as one of
the hitchhikers guides
um uh little um
episodes that everything vanishes in a
proof of logic
and that's where you would ultimately
end up going so the reason i mentioned
that is when you say the word
observation
it can mean very different things
depending on where we are in this whole
edifice this philosophy house where
we're stripping out assumptions and so
on
in the context of inference devices
observation is just like prediction
control or memory for that matter
it's just a way for you to be posing
questions you then have an observation
device
that is providing you answers
and what the um things like the apostles
demon theorem and all these kinds of
things prove to you
is that you no matter what the
observation device is they're always
going to be situations where the answer
gives you is wrong
so that's what observation means in the
context of inference devices it means
other things in other contexts